[Music]
so chuck i've got an obscure one for you
okay
okay there's a fellow named einrich
wilhelm olbers
where are the papers
they must be peer reviewed
okay
do you narrate the history channel or
something
so
he lived in the late 1700s early 1800s
and he formulated
a question that i think had been banning
about for a while but he's it's got his
name on this
okay he posed a
a profound question
which was
why is the night sky dark
okay
i i mean
i'm gonna save him some trouble i got
the answer oh you have the answer okay
because that answer didn't arrive until
like the 1920s so you tell me you have
an answer okay go ahead let me hear it
as simple as this
because it's night time
boom
because the sunset they were just there
we saw it go down bro now it's dark
okay no that ain't how that works okay
okay all right so i'm going to say
something mathematically subtle
which is at the heart of this but i'm
adding it just for people to hear the
little bit of extra math
but
uh i could describe it without the math
but i'd rather not okay right here it
goes um let's take the sun
for a moment okay all right and it has a
certain size on the sky
and there's a certain amount of light
coming from the sun and it's it's very
bright
okay but there's something called
surface brightness
it's a very important term in
astrophysics so it's not what the total
brightness of the thing is
it's how much light is coming
from a particular area on the sky
okay so that would be a surface
brightness
surface brightness okay
so now watch what happens
if i put the sun three times farther
away
right
its area on the sky
drops
to one ninth of what it was before it
goes as the square of the distance okay
all right okay so it's one-ninth as
large
okay because three times farther away
it's like one-third it's height and it's
one-third in the width and in the area
you're down by a factor of nine okay so
that's the mathematics of that right
it's one-ninth as large
are you with me i'm with you okay
i mean or as i would say
is smaller
okay good okay so but precisely one
night not only that
if it's three times farther away
something called the inverse square law
of light
drops the total brightness
by the distance squared
so if it's three times farther away
three squared is nine the brightness
you're receiving from the sun
is only one-ninth of what it was before
okay
well wait a minute
if the sun is one-ninth is large and
you're getting one-ninth the
light if you divide those two then
one-ninths cancel it has the same
surface brightness as it did when it was
closer
oh
well that was a neat little trick that's
what i'm saying it's a it's a
mathematical reality of the geometry of
what's going on
okay
so what what that means is
you could put the sun
at any distance from you
and a sight line to its surface
will be just as bright as a sight line
to a air a spot on its surface if it's
close up
right okay that makes sense
okay so
albers
you you forgot about him right
yeah
tell me who didn't know why night time
exists
dumbass
tom that's what it means in germany
[Laughter]
i'm ass in the dark
so he said to himself
if the universe
is infinite
okay then every sight line
should land on a star
and if every sight line lands on a star
then the entire night sky should be
as bright as the surface of the sun
whoa
it should be ablaze
in light
okay for this reason that i told you
yes because
even though you're moving them farther
away
they cancel out in the inverse ratio
correct inverse square ratio right
inverse square root okay so and so boom
it's still just as bright so now doesn't
matter
yes so the surface brightness and you're
talking about where you land on the sky
right the site so if you have an
infinite universe and stars are
everywhere you'd have your sightline
would eventually hit the surface of a
star right and the surface of a star
would then be just as bright i mean
within the variations of stars you know
be just as bright as the surface of the
sun
and so
that was the paradox
no darkness
correct and so the night sky is not
completely dark so the paradox is
if we live in an infinite universe the
night sky should be a blazing light and
it's not
so therefore we must not live in an
infinite universe this was his
conclusion
okay right okay
so nobody knows if we were living in an
infinite universe we had no idea you had
no idea all anybody ever knew were the
stars at night and the fuzzy things were
just fuzzy things we in fact we call
them all nebulae which is latin for
fuzzy thing all right and
only in the 1920s with the work of edwin
hubble 1926 he was going to show that
the spiral fuzzy things in the night sky
are at huge distances from us
and in fact
they're twins of our own milky way
their other galaxies
so
the universe maybe we don't think of it
as filled with stars maybe it's filled
with galaxies but same difference you
would still land on a star in that other
galaxy so he first discovers that but
then
here was the kicker
1929 he discovers that the universe is
expanding
oh my gosh so you know what that means
it means the starlight dims at a faster
rate
than one over the distance square the
one over the the inverse square law of
light right because the light is trying
to reach you and the universe says that
it's almost pulled away i'm going no i'm
going to stretch you out too well and
dilute you before you even get to your
destination what
so even if we did live in an infinite
universe at the time unknown
the fact that we're in an expanding
universe is sufficient to solve albert's
paradox
look at that
that's right that i mean that's pretty
fascinating it is and
and
the speed of light is finite
it's not infinite so
a second solution to the paradox is if
you go far enough in the universe even
if it wasn't expanding even if we were
not in an expanding universe you could
reach a point
where the universe is not old enough for
the light from that object to have
reached you
right
so you're not adding up all this light
that his original thought experiment
would give you
because the light just isn't there even
if it is there waiting to knock on your
front door right because it hasn't
reached your front door yet exactly so
by the 1920s like an uber
on that little app you see where the car
is
you know it's there but it's not it's
not there to pick you up yet
right yeah it's it's
well except yeah we presume the uber's
right it's not exactly phantom shadow of
an uber
so so it's an interesting fact
that this paradox had multiple
sort of inline solutions that solved it
otherwise right there'd be no dark sky
period super cool man yeah no no yeah we
could have we could have lived in a
finite universe right the stars in our
galaxy that's it you know and that's not
enough stars for every sight line to
land on one so
yeah
yeah wow that's pretty that's absolutely
cool it's called olbers
paradox right and what it does is it
reaffirms for us
the fact that even if the actual
universe were infinite
the fact that the speed of light
is not
infinite
tells us we only see out to our horizon
that's it you don't see you can't see to
infinity because the speed of light is
limited
so who would have known that the the
paradox had multiple solutions for it so
you don't always get that in science
yeah well it's i think you certainly
don't get that by going mommy why is it
so dark
so i would say when your kids say why is
it dark at night right if you say cause
the sun set because no you you you no
you're the dumbass
exactly
mommy why does his blessings get dark at
night well sweetie you know clearly this
so you trying to tell me you don't know
albert's paradigm
i was just saying mom yeah yeah the
eight-year-old i just listened to star
talk and you idiot
there you go kids if you want to be able
to call your parents idiots
go look up ober's paradox and then ask
them why does it get dark
in all fairness to parents that day will
happen
with or without us so you might
that day will arrive okay
so true it's so true so might as well be
in the safe space of star talk right
where you can have that happen let it be
in service to science
exactly yeah that's cool so that's it
chuck that's ober's paradox that's very
cool i love it i love ogre's paradox you
got it you got it i apologize to him
publicly i know he's dead but i'm going
to still apologize
clearly you're not as dumb as i thought
well no you can do that's you can give a
better apology than that clearly you're
smarter than i ever thought i was how
about that oh well there you go
that would be an honest apology that's
an honest apology yeah all right chuck
always good to have you man always a
pleasure star talk explainer video neil
degrasse tyson
keep looking up
[Music]